Tyco and WorldCom are some of the
companies profiled in William Black's
new book the best way to rob a bank is
to own one this is just over an hour
tonight to welcome William K Black the
executive director of the Institute for
fraud prevention he is going to discuss
and sign his book the best way to rob a
bank is to own one
the catastrophic collapse of companies
such as Enron WorldCom M clone and Tyco
left angry investors employees reporters
and government investigators demanding
to know how the CEOs deceived everyone
into believing their companies were
spectacularly successful when in fact
they were massively insolvent why did
the nation's top accounting firms give
such companies clean audit reports where
were the regulators and whistleblowers
who should expose fraudulent CEOs before
they loot their companies for hundreds
of millions of dollars in this expert
insiders account of the Savings and Loan
debacle of the 1980s
William Black lays bare the strategies
that corrupt CEOs and CFOs in collusion
with those who have regulatory oversight
of their industries used to defraud
companies for their personal gain
recounting the investigations he
conducted as director of litigation for
the Federal Home Loan Bank board black
fully reveals how Charles Keating and
hundreds of other SNL owners took
advantage of a weak regulatory
environment to perpetuate accounting
fraud on a massive scale
he also authoritative Lee links the SNL
crash to the business failures of the
early 2000s showing how CEOs then and
now are using the same tactics to defeat
regulatory restraints and commit the
same types of destructive fraud black
uses the latest advances in criminology
and economics to develop a theory of why
control fraud looting a company for
personal profit tends to occur in waves
that make financial markets deeply
inefficient he also explains how to
prevent such waves throughout the book
black drives home the larger point that
control fraud is a major ongoing threat
in business that requires active
independent regulators to contain it his
book is a wake-up call for everyone who
believes that market forces alone will
keep companies and their owners honest
ladies and gentlemen please give a warm
welcome to this
William Black thank all of you thank you
borders for staging this I'll start out
with why I wrote this book it was from
frustration in large part that we had
learned lessons from the savings and
loan crisis that helped produce the next
crisis instead of helping to prevent the
next crisis it's the old thing about you
don't get disasters from ignorance
you get disasters from the things that
you think you know which aren't true and
we thought we knew a number of things
after the Savings and Loan debacle that
proved to be completely untrue and
because we designed a regulatory system
in light of those false beliefs we've
had the new and even larger series of
crises involving control fraud control
fraud is simply a situation in which the
person controlling the organization
whether it is a corporation or whether
it is a nation uses their ability to
control that organization to loot it or
to loot customers in the modern
situation is primarily been looting the
creditors looting the shareholders the
final absurdity of all this was driven
home to me in 2003 when the Justice
Department announced in a press release
that property crimes had fallen to an
all-time historical low except of course
unless fraud is a property crime in
which case property crimes had risen to
an all-time historical high and of
course they are property crimes and of
course the answer is we don't count them
nobody in the United States is
responsible for counting the major
frauds there are no reports on it and as
a result they essentially don't exist
for many political purposes and that is
an obscenity in the context of these
kinds of frauds because even on an
individual basis the large control
Rod's cause greater financial losses
than all other forms of property crimes
combined in the nation right so the
thing we're not counting is bigger by
far than everything we do count and that
means that we tend to focus our
resources and absolutely the wrong areas
and absolutely the wrong way in control
fraud the CEO typically uses the firm as
a weapon but also as a victim
simultaneously to loot debt to loot its
creditors and to loot its shareholders
and these control frauds cause these
amazingly large losses as I said much
greater than all it affirms a property
crime combined because they can do five
unique things the first thing they can
do is because the CEO hires and fires
all of the internal controls and
virtually all of the external controls
external controls are things like your
outside auditor they can get rid of them
and they can hire the right kind of ones
so they don't simply defeat internal and
external controls that's actually the
wrong premise they suborn them and turn
them into their most valuable ally so a
clean opinion from a top-tier audit firm
is the best thing you can have going as
a control fraud and you've seen in the
Savings and Loan debacle and then again
recently that every single one of them
was able to get clean opinions from top
tier audit firms typically for year
after year
Keating's famous phrase was his
accountants were a profit center and
that was exactly true
the second thing that you can do is you
can optimize the firm for fraud because
you are the CEO and that largely means
two things both of which relate to the
fact that if you are a control fraud
your weapon of choice is accounting
fraud how do you do accounting fraud
best first thing you do is you invest
in areas that have no clear market value
you don't run these scams in something
like wheat where everybody knows the
price per bushel of the wheat you run it
in things in the savings and loan crisis
like massive office buildings massive
unique office buildings they have no
clear market value your home if you're
especially in a track is easy to figure
out the value within plus or minus 5%
you go to your neighbors open house you
find what your neighbors house sold for
you can make a very good estimate of
what your home is worth that is not true
of large office buildings which have no
clear comparables the second thing that
you do is you grow extremely rapidly and
so these largest control frauds the
reasons they cause such massive losses
is that they become Ponzi schemes and a
Ponzi scheme you grow very rapidly and
you pay off for a while obviously the
old debts with the new debts but you're
accumulating all the time ever greater
debts that will eventually lead to
catastrophic losses and a CEO can do
both of these things the CEO can say we
will now invest in the following
business lines exclusively and so it's
savings and loan after savings and loan
the new corrupt CEO would come in they
would stop doing home lending and they
would immediately go towards lending
almost entirely for these large
commercial office building structures
and they would grow and they would grow
massively the control frauds in the
Savings and Loan industry averaged more
than 50 percent growth per annum before
the reregulate set in I don't know if
that seems like a lot or a little
it's an extraordinary growth rate that
is completely unsustainable and quickly
leads to these kinds of Ponzi disasters
the third thing that they can do and
this is what converts it from simply
being a financial scandal to a political
scandal as well is when you're control
fraud you
use the resources of the firm and the
apparent legitimacy of the firm that you
control to change the external
environment so not within the firm but
classically of course you can change
regulation and so in Enron's case we had
the famous situation that Ken Lay
bragged about creating the regulatory
black hole in energy derivatives and
because no one regulated it he was able
to use that in conjunction with other
members of the cartel to produce the
California energy crisis and very large
profits to Enron and obviously very
severe problems for the citizens of
California and Oregon and other Pacific
Northwest regions in the savings and
loan crisis this was even more dramatic
probably because it was one of the
striking features of the savings and
loan crisis that the greatest political
intervention took place for the two
worst control frauds in the nation
Vernon Savings and Loan known in the
regulatory ranks as Berman savings and
Lincoln Savings and Loan Charles
Keating's infamous Savings and Loan
and so speaker right and in the United
States sort of the answer to a trivia
question who is the most second most
powerful politically elected official in
America it's the Speaker of the House
well the speaker right went to bat for
Vernon Savings and he went to bat for
Charles Keating's Lincoln Savings and of
course the Keating five the five US
senators so historically went to bat as
well for Lincoln Savings vernon savings
96% of its loans defaulted right and if
you thought that's just because of the
bad Texas economy 92% of its loans
outside of Texas defaulted Lincoln
Savings was the most expensive financial
failure financial institution failure in
US history remains that at over three
billion dollars on a shop that was only
six billion dollars in two
the liabilities so he was losing money
at roughly 30 million dollars per
working day Charles Keating if you want
to think about the rate at which these
people are able to do it and so the
extraordinary thing is the absolute
worst frauds were able to get the
greatest political intervention and this
political intervention was so powerful
that the legitimate members of the
industry the trade association
represented them reached what some of
its own members refer to as the Faustian
bargain in other words the bargain with
the devil in which they would support
each other to get their common goals
which was virtually no new funds for the
Federal Savings Loan Insurance
Corporation which we call physic and
what were called forbearance provisions
which were really provisions designed to
gut our ability to take enforcement and
of course the really sad thing is that
from a perspective of a firm that's
engaged in fraud a very large political
contribution is trivial as I say Keating
was losing 30 million dollars per
business day a $50,000 contribution is
nothing in that situation a $50,000
contribution even today is a very
important contribution that will put you
on a first-name basis right so changing
the external environment is something
unique to control frauds and the answer
is they could all do it it's only
audacity that keep or lack of audacity
that keeps a number of the frauds from
doing so but all of them could easily
fund very large contributions and many
of them do and collectively that can
cause enormous problems in our political
system
the fourth thing that they can do
uniquely control frauds is to take money
out of the firm using seemingly
legitimate normal corporate mechanism
and this comes back to why control
frauds use accounting fraud as their
weapon of choice
if you're an embezzler if you stick your
money in the till you have no defense
when you're caught right they what do
you say I meant to put it back I was
hoping to put it back in awhile that's
the typical defense you get an
embezzlement case and typically it takes
the jury about ten minutes to come back
with a guilty verdict in those
circumstances but if you use accounting
fraud you don't look like you're you
know okay as a business you look like
you are extraordinarily profitable if
you engage in accounting fraud and if
you grow rapidly you are mathematically
guaranteed it's not a matter of risk you
are mathematically guaranteed to report
that you are one of the most profitable
entities in the world and so Vernon
savings reported it was the most
profitable Savings and Loan in America
and Lincoln Savings in a later year
reported it was the most profitable
Savings and Loan in America and of
course Enron reported it was one of the
most profitable corporations in all the
world and worldcom and you can go
through the entire list in the period
when they're using the accounting fraud
and growing very rapidly they all report
extraordinary profits and that's how
important these frauds are it's not a
firm that makes itself you know that's
slightly insolvent makes itself look
slightly profitable it's a firm like
Enron that that is insolvent to the tune
of 85 percent of its reported assets
that's able to picture itself as if it's
one of the most profitable firms in the
world to get a clean audit opinion for
years saying that and to have investors
treat it as if it's real that's what
allows you to cause tens of billions of
dollars of losses and it's why even
individual large control frauds as I say
caused greater losses than all other
forms of property crimes combined and
that is the extraordinary danger that
you can get people
to believe these things and so look at
fast Isle the infamous chief financial
officer CFO of Enron the man was
technically incompetent you may have
read the book or you may be familiar
with it the brightest folk guys in the
room they're nowhere near the brightest
guys in the room they're the most
audacious people in the room the least
ethically concerned people in the world
and so fast I for example kept a complex
equation for solving the value of
complex financial derivative in his
office on a whiteboard but he couldn't
do the equation it was the equivalent of
people who buy books and put them at the
back of their office that they've never
read and could never read and he was
named the best chief financial officer
in the nation by CFO magazine the degree
to which these frauds are able to fool
people is extraordinary and if you are
extraordinarily profitable as a firm
then what happens to the CEO in the
modern world stock options appreciation
of the stock bonuses perks like you
cannot believe
that read like you know the dying days
of Rome type of thing in terms of excess
are all done norm and all that none of
those things require you to ever put
your hand in the till which is why you
can catch people red-handed you can have
four chief financial officers testify
that the CFO ordered you to engage in
this fraud and they can be acquitted at
least in particular states they can be
acquitted if you're mister scratching
and the last thing that you can do
that's special to these frauds unique to
them is you can burnish the legitimacy
of the firm and your own legitimacy and
status using the firm's resources so it
is absolutely the norm for these control
frauds to start becoming great givers to
charity but with our
money not theirs right and that of
course helps them as well should there
ever be a criminal investigation now the
remarkable thing about the savings and
loan crisis I would suggest is twofold
given the hundreds of control frauds
that were operating one is we were
extraordinarily fortunate that the
Savings Loan debacle was only a debacle
logically it was headed for catastrophic
reaches and as a result of in part the
actions of a number of people in the
audience here
it was prevented from becoming a
complete catastrophe and it's only up to
its time the worst financial scandal in
US history it's of course been passed by
the current frauds the second thing is
and it comes from it perhaps that was
the problem
perhaps if the folks in this room and
elsewhere in the regulatory ranks had
actually done what the economists claim
we did you would have had a catastrophe
which would have given fraud a bad name
and led to bigger reforms perhaps
consider the following examples speaker
Wright is holding the Federal Savings
Loan Insurance Corporation bill that's
going to give money to physic hostage to
extort favors for Don Dixon of Vermin
savings and similar control frauds in
Texas and he demands of the chairman of
the agency Ed gray that he fired Joe
Selby the top regulator in Texas saying
that he's a homosexual and running a
ring of homosexual lawyers you know
preposterous bizarre stuff any logical
person in Gray's position since physic
was down to five hundred million dollars
in funds to insure an industry with it
roughly a trillion dollars in assets
might well have given in
think what would have happened if Edie
gray had given in to that extortion
speaker was thinking what speaker writes
ethics investigation would have been
like in those circumstances then think
of the Keating five the Keating five
demanded of again chairman gray that a
Lincoln Savings which had violated the
direct investment rule to the tune of
over six hundred million dollars be
given immunity for that violation that's
what that meeting was all about what if
gray had said yes can you imagine what
the Keating five Senate investigation
would have been like when he then
produced a three billion dollar loss
plus an immense fraud targeted at widows
who were left uninsured to the tune of
22,000 of them losing roughly three
hundred million dollars so in a bizarre
way if Edie gray had not stood up to
these people he actually would have
caused far more catastrophic political
changes in the coming investigations in
other words their most fortunate thing
was that they were dealing with that
gray and not a more normal regulator but
then considered the bizarreness of the
conventional economic wisdom which is
that the agency was quote captured by
the industry it regulated which is why
they were trying so hire hard to fire ed
gray and why they were trying so hard to
claim that people were homosexuals and
should be driven out of office and why
they were suing us for four hundred
million dollars in our individual
capacity and why they were writing memos
get black kill him dead I don't think
that squares well with regulatory
capture indeed I think it's so far the
opposite that it is bizarre that the
conventional economic wisdom ended up
being complete fiction that has nothing
to do with the debacle
it's a time after time we had the
bazzara stealing of knowing I'm a
Democrat for example I'm in the room
with Jim right and I'm trying to warn
him off from helping vermin savings I'm
his only friend in the room I'm his best
friend in the room and he's screaming
and cursing at me right and many people
in this room had experiences a bit
similar where we continued to do our job
and continue to try to give the best
advice we could to people who generally
speaking thought we were outrageous I
don't want to leave on that note because
you know I am someone who actually
believes we are in a great country and
we there were substantial exceptions to
this despite all the money despite the
fact that the only thing that could
possibly cost someone like Henry B
Gonzales his safe seat in Congress was
going to bat against the interests of
Texas as it would have been portrayed by
the Texas savings and loans and despite
that and despite the fact that the
Democratic Party desperately didn't want
him to go forward with hearings on the
Lincoln Savings disaster because of the
role of the Keating five and four of
those five senators were Democrats
despite that fact he went forward and
people like Jim leach this wasn't simply
you know heroic Democrats Jim Leach was
very supportive of that effort as well
and didn't turn it into some kind of
political circus aimed at Democrats but
aimed far more at the truth so I think
that in terms of time I would much
prefer to be talking with you instead of
at you
I have largely not done the anecdotes to
say with a substance to begin with and
I'd like to turn it over to questions at
this point
about anything and everything you're
interested in the debacle
yes
like mr. Gonzales I'm sorry how much can
be striped the guy to your left
that's right how much could be
structurally changed in the uniforms
you'd like to see and how much really
are we all dependent upon a lot of
people sitting here
structure and individuals are both
important and they're both reinforcing
in positive and in negative directions
so what did we do I said we learned the
wrong lessons well one of the first
things we did was get rid of the Federal
Home Loan Bank board as an independent
regulatory agency because of course all
executive branch is hate independent
regulatory agencies and no one like Ed
gray could have arisen in an executive
branch agency and said no to all these
things and have reregulate addition
everywhere he looked so the first
institutional change we made made it
harder similarly we should have learned
institutionally one of the you know the
no-brainers about the savings and loan
crisis Savings and Loan examiner's were
paid considerably less than banking
examiner's duh what do you think is
going to happen in those circumstances
so not only were we not permitted to
hire many examiner's whatever limit they
gave us we often couldn't meet because
we couldn't get them or they would leave
because they've learned they could get
20% more by going to the banking
agencies flash forward in time to the
90s and of course to this decade and we
decided the SEC the Securities and
Exchange Commission shouldn't be allowed
to pay its people for comparable
positions as much as the banking
regulatory agencies and we decided it
would be a really good idea to save
money by having far fewer SEC reviewers
and so when I was a young lawyer and we
were dealing with business clients we
could say you better do it right because
the SEC is vigorous and Stan sporkin
will come he was the enforcement
director of the SEC at that point and he
will come in bash you so let's do it
clean and that gave us the leverage to
get with business clients where they
would go yeah yeah I guess we're better
in that era most in fact a great bulk of
securities filings were actually
reviewed by somebody at the SEC
by the time of the crisis with Enron at
all it was down to closer to 5% of
securities filings were actually
reviewed at the SEC which meant you
could get away with it
and in case of Enron for example I think
the last time they looked at an Enron
filing was 1988
I'm sorry 1998 all right and under any
logical system we should have learned
some lessons we learned in the savings
and loan crisis as well which is you
can't use your resources just spread
evenly you have to triage you have to
find the most dangerous situations which
clearly would have been the Enron's of
the world and put more of your resources
there and look at them we didn't do that
as well we don't still I was talking
about this from one of my former
students working with the GAO who I will
allow to remain nameless unless I
causing troubles but we still at the GAO
have the responsibility to identify
high-risk activities but the SCC's
anti-fraud activities are still not
listed as a high-risk activity why
because if they foul up the money isn't
lost to Treasury it's lost to
shareholders and Gao only treats it as
high-risk as if the money is directly
lost by the shareholders so if EPA fails
in its mission and people die that's not
a high-risk activity we ought to change
those types of things institutionally to
come back to people ultimately people
are still critical and people are hard
to predict but you ought to care enough
to try to send the very best and that's
rare as opposed to the norm and it's
getting more ideological and at the
assistant secretary level and below and
the special assistants it's
extraordinarily ideological more so than
in my lifetime and probably lifetime of
others in this room as well
next sir
if you could comment on the
effectiveness of the sarbanes-oxley act
in addressing some of the concerns that
you talked about in your book
sarbanes-oxley in my view is not well
directed towards solving the problems of
control fraud it does create some
benefits in the accounting realm and
we'll see how they pan out I mean we
obviously in a situation in which the
SEC Chairman was removed because he was
viewed as too vigorous William Donaldson
but in a sense I'm being unfair and I
should come back to your question
William Donaldson was not removed he
resigned now the administration made it
clear that it wanted him to resign but
it made very clear that it wanted had
greater resign and Ed gray refused to go
William Donaldson even though he is at
the end of his career independently
wealthy and has a reputation beyond you
know God's representative on earth in
these terms and doesn't have to worry
about it left and I haven't seen any
story that even asked the ethical
question should you resign in the
circumstances when you know the reason
you're being pushed out is to bring in
the leading opponent of reform and of
course previously Harvey Pitt was
selected for one reason only because he
was the leading opponent of accounting
reform in America right when we do those
kinds of things we produce disasters
again now sarbanes-oxley can't solve
that so it's the people at the top that
matter the most and of course they were
going to put in someone who was a very
distinguished gentleman but had no
knowledge of accounting that was the
Webster thing as well so three out of
four very bad choices have defeated I
think anything that sarbanes-oxley was
designed to accomplish I'd note also
that the person they put in charge of
the Justice Department cleanup had been
at Providian in a situation where he
didn't find huge fraud at his own
company for year after year that he was
directly responsible for overseeing
those kinds of things we we can do
better I mean there are lots of people
out there just as were brought in to
clean up the Savings & Loan industry and
again are often in the audience here
could be used people analogous to them
to clean up the more general securities
industry yes
I
the serial acquirers the way they used
merger accounting to disguise my
weaknesses that report
the question was I spend a great deal of
time talking about goodwill mergers and
the accounting aspects of that in the
book as it was used in the savings and
loan crisis to produce fictional income
and net worth we're there analogues in
the current crises including Tyco and
perhaps WorldCom and others that did
substantial mergers a number of those
areas of accounting abuse were actually
cleaned up and I want to be in fairness
to them professional accountants as a
profession they have often been
constructive and I would say this in is
in distinction to my profession which is
the law which has rarely been
constructive in terms of how we our
profession has been assisting these
frauds I don't have lets tell you it
drove me berserk to hear lawyer after
lawyers saying but of course I have to
give zealous advocacy to my client I
said yes
your client is the savings and loan the
CEO is not your client he's looting and
destroying your client and you're giving
zealous help to him we're trying to save
your client so no the accounting
scandals were do scandals but they used
the same fundamental device which is
make sure you're invited doing it in
something that doesn't have a clear
market value and so Enron scandals
involve overwhelmingly selling business
operations that had no clear market
value and then Enron simply put its own
value and surprise it said they were
massively valuable when they were in
fact worth essentially worthless in most
of these situations so the exact
mechanisms have changed the fundamentals
of the accounting abuse are the same
I'm sorry I arrived late and you may
have already addressed this but have you
got any thoughts on the pending GST
legislation yes we it comes back to the
institutional question and the people
question we set up a situation in which
the de GST the question is about the
GSEs and those are the
government-sponsored enterprises
particularly I think in the housing
context was the nature of the question
and have we learned any lessons there I
that's another area where we didn't
learn the lessons and then we had to
learn them anew after a scandals in that
situation we set up incredibly powerful
entities that I talked about how you
could shape the external environment if
you controlled the firm well
few people have ever been better than
Fannie and Freddie at shaping the
external environment an enormous number
of people probably a number of people in
this room and have been on their payroll
at one time or another in doing
something noble by the way not something
terrible because that's how you do it
you do initiatives for all kinds of
things that appeal to a wide range of
people and then you use complexity and
that's what we've seen in the
government-sponsored enterprises to a
fare-thee-well I mean they have made the
accounting so complex so arcane that it
would take tremendous resources to be
able to look through to what's really
happening and they know that the
government's at a tremendous comparative
disadvantage in fighting accounting
battles first because so many things are
gray areas where they can simply say our
judgment is different than yours but
also because they can pay the outside
accountants and their internal
accountants far more than we can pay in
the governmental ranks and that means
that they're being smart tactically and
we have to get much smarter
as a government in terms of how we set
up the regulation so that means actually
paying people and having a way to keep
expertise in the government and have the
you have you be an expert without being
an office head right we too often we the
only way to promotion is to make you
head of Peter Principle type thing where
you do something else as opposed to no
Wall Street pays people lots and lots of
money to do things that they have
expertise in and they keep doing it year
after year so we know how to do it we
know some of the restraints in terms of
congressional feeling about pay but it
is one of those classic pay me now or
pay me later situations and to give you
an idea of all this at one point there
our stock markets lost nine trillion
dollars in market capitalization okay a
trillion is a thousand billion so this
is not in Everett Dirksen situation that
a trillion here a trillion there sooner
or later you're talking about real money
a trillion is greater than the GDP of
all but forty nations in the world nine
trillion was equivalent essentially to
the entire GDP of the United States of
America so I'd rather spend another 2.6
million and get some good accountants
and some good capital market specialists
and keep them from being hired away by
Freddie and Fannie which would be the
next problem many parts of the country
financial institution says to giving lis
increase the percentage of variable rate
loans or no interest loans that they're
making what are the lessons that you see
from the prior crisis most concerned
about today we're already behind it of
course because the bubble has been many
years in the making but yes the the
question is should we have learned
anything from past crises about how to
deal with bubbles and that is one of the
the great questions and the hardest
questions because bubbles are wonderful
things I mean afterwards people say
nasty things about bubbles but during
bubbles they're wonderful because we all
own homes and our homes are going up in
value you know and what would we think
if someone deliberately put the kibosh
on all this and caused housing values to
fall 20% would we hail that person as a
hero that's choice one I don't think so
and so you almost never get someone
deliberately breaking a bubble by the
way the exception to that would be the
savings and loan crisis we're attacking
the control frauds because again a Ponzi
scheme will increase its lending in the
face of a bubble even as a glut occurs
was something in conjunction with the 86
Tax Act that was deliberately done to
help break that bubble and it was
enormous ly successful at doing so so is
someone gonna have the courage to do it
at the Fed level not a chance at the
regulatory level I think you can do it
by not calling what you're doing
fighting a bubble but instead calling it
dealing with prudent lending and so
there are far too many negative
amortization and similar loans as you've
talked about and we could limit them in
the regulatory ranks and we have at
times limited them in the past that at a
minimum will mean that a number of
savings and loans and banks will not get
into financial trouble or at least not
and nowhere near as deep of financial
trouble and I not with the
agencies anymore but I would urge them
to do it but not call it a fight against
the bubble just do it on the basis of
and add in consumer education if I were
doing it and that one's serious actually
I think that there's an there enormous
number of homeowners who do not
understand what will happen in the event
of the bubble bursting in Texas where I
now teach hundreds of thousands of
people lost their home when you start
losing your home especially in America
especially in these periods when people
are so heavily in debt we are talking
about homeless situations for a
significant number of those people so I
don't think that people understand the
risk they're taking on these kinds of
loans and seriously I would encourage
and a strong initiative in the
regulatory ranks on those kinds of loans
right now you know six six months ago a
year ago but now at but the best we can
do
yes after successive waves of fraud
described
the question is after these successive
waves of fraud why have we still learned
the wrong lessons in large part because
the group that's created the
conventional wisdom is the group that
helped produce the savings-and-loan
disaster and that's primarily the
economists who said that deregulation
was a wonderful thing and that it would
bring all kinds of wonderful results and
it produced a disaster instead now you
have two choices in that circumstance
you can say I'm sorry I misled you I was
wrong I didn't understand economics very
well that be choice one that was taken
by none or you could say to the death
deregulation had nothing to do with it
fraud had nothing to do with it it's
only Deposit Insurance we have to get
rid of Deposit Insurance except that the
savings and loan crisis disproved that I
mean the theory would deposit insurance
from an economics perspective is this
because of you have deposit insurance as
a depositor you have no incentive to
care whether the bank or Savings and
Loan is healthy you're guaranteed to
take the highest rate and there is
substantial truth to that but savings
and loans sold stock nobody insured
those shareholders and those
shareholders were supposed to under
economic theory impose what's called
market discipline and there in no case
during the Savings and Loan debacle was
their effective market discipline from
shareholders against the control fraud
not a single case and there was none in
the current wave of frauds either in the
Savings and Loan debacle there were also
people called subordinated debt holders
the forgetting the fancy terms these are
people who have a substantial incentive
to make sure the savings alone is
healthy and they're supposed to have
expertise unusual expertise in being
able to evaluate that there is not a
single case where subordinated debt
holders exercised effective market
discipline in the Savings and Loan
debacle or in the current wave of frauds
and you can do the same thing on loan to
participation x' because people who
other SNL's who bought loan
participations stood to lose money but
loan participants never exercised
effective market discipline the reason
ultimately is that all of these things
have been saying challenge the efficient
market hypothesis which is the heart of
modern finance so if you're an economist
it wouldn't be just saying oops I'm
sorry I messed up personally it would be
oops I'm sorry
and the fundamental thing I've been
telling you and basing all of my policy
recommendations on for 25 years at the
time now 35 years is either wrong or has
very important exceptions whenever there
is substantial fraud and worse I have no
theory at all or knowledge about fraud
so I no longer need to be paid $500 an
hour as a consultant because I actually
have no expertise that's useful in this
regard so there's no chance that
economists were going to take that
position in fairness George Akerlof
Nobel Prize winner in economics person
on the back of the book saying nice
things about the book said the same type
of things that I did we work together
back in 1993 you would think if a Nobel
Prize winner in economics said the
conventional economic wisdom was wrong
people would at least cite him and
disagree with him if they disagreed with
them they simply ignore it
overwhelmingly in most economic accounts
of the event that's extraordinary to me
and sad about I teach microeconomics I
don't teach it that way but I'm still
sad to see the profession result in that
react in that fashion because of
embarrassment I think in large part yes
20/20 hindsight what are some of the
accounting red flags that you should
have looked for and do you think that's
applicable to investing in companies
today you know the way to resync
corporate fraud really good question the
question was given what we know now if
hindsight was actually accurate and by
the way I argue in the book it isn't is
one of the key things what would we look
for then during the savings alone
tobacco if we were investors to try to
spot the frauds and what should we look
for in the future and we have one of the
people in the room who looked for
savings and loans that would have the
characteristics that they were likely to
fail and we were actually very effective
in identifying those in advance by
looking for a couple of things first you
know every time there's a little fraud
and some typically you know elderly
woman is how the news accounts go who
bought something an investment where
they were promised a 50% return someone
goes through or her plight and then says
but of course it was too good to be true
you can you know you can have only
limited sympathy for but why don't we
apply that to Enron right how is it that
Enron could invest in any activity in
the world and immediately do better than
everybody else why was that a believable
story in terms of finance or economic
theory or business theory it isn't it is
too good to be true they were reporting
vastly to greater profits and so the
first thing you would look for is who
are the folks reporting that they are
the 15 most profitable Savings & Loan in
America they have a extraordinarily high
percentage a probability of being frauds
and you would have avoided the top 15
the second thing you would have looked
for is the pattern
what are they investing in do they
diversify or are they pumped everything
into acquisition development
construction lending in the context of
the savings and loans and have they done
it in
let's look at the vacancy rate and you
would have seen as early as 1983 that
Texas vacancy rates had reached record
levels and of course if that continues
to grow because these Ponzi schemes
continue to increase lending and it's
only when ed Gray slaps the growth
restrictions on that this fails to
become an absolute calamity take it
forward in time as I said what could
possibly lead to Enron being massively
profitable the first thing you look for
is a difference between cash what's
happening on a cash basis and what's
happening on their accounting basis and
if you had looked at Enron you would see
they were claiming enormous profits on
an accounting basis and the cash flow
suggested losses not even tiny profits
actual losses given what they would have
to carry in terms of their debt and such
so that would been the most useful thing
and again looking are they investing in
areas where I am dependent entirely on
some accounting firm blessing numbers
that no one else can figure out if it is
pass it up right it's too great a risk
it might not be a fraud but from an
individual standpoint pass it up
get a diversified portfolio you know go
long term
question is how did Bush 1 justify
bailing out the uninsured portion of the
counts on his own authority how did that
happen the answer generally speaking is
he didn't the there was actual authority
under for the for real legislation in
1989 but if I could do an answer similar
to what's perhaps going to where you're
going
most Danny wall decided not to liquidate
institutions even when it would be
cheaper to liquidate the institutions
and in the liquidation you don't pay off
uninsured folks and Larry white and his
book says but it only happened four or
five times and he can
Danny wall chose to bail out
institutions even though if you the
alleged cost savings was coming from tax
savings but wait a minute were the
federal government any tax savings comes
from us and is really a cost not a
savings so those type of things occurred
they occurred in the last year of
President Reagan's presidency with the
full support of Vice President Bush but
as soon as January rolled around Danny
wall was told he was not permitted to do
a single New Deal after the election and
the federal savings alone insurance
corporation was not permitted to be
conservator or receiver for anymore
failures after I think late January of
1989 so Bush knew how bad and how
out-of-control things were it was useful
to get past the election and Danny wall
has been quite candid in saying he was a
good soldier who his phrase is in his
testimony to Congress
everyone knew I was talking in code is
his phrase so what he said we don't
really need federal funds that was code
for we really need
federal funds so it's not a lie because
everybody knew he was lying if you
follow me how did depositors get their
money back they got their monies back
from us as taxpayers there was a and
overwhelmingly deposits were insured if
you look it would be on the average of
about ninety nine point two percent of
all deposits in a failed SNL were in
fact insured so there isn't much
uninsured money in the typical Savings
and Loan particularly in that era
because people knew that the Insurance
Fund was insolvent and you'd be nuts to
keep very much money at an uninsured
account so banks big banks are different
they have lots of uninsured money you
know they have accounts for twenty
million dollars savings and loans rarely
had that kind of thing per institution
so you could have there were roughly
3,000 institutions you could have many
millions of dollars fully insured in
savings and loans so I think it's a
little different than you say but the
general point that bush knew that the
Bank word was up to very strange things
got past the election and then
immediately shut it down is a true point
in something that I mentioned the book
yes
seem to remember that the the S&L issues
never became a shouting issue
in any of the presidential elections I
assumed that that was no one was trying
to cause a run or anything like that
what would be your explanation to be
assuming that my memories correct yeah
your your memories absolutely right that
the Savings and Loan debacle never
became a major political issue in the
presidential campaigns and the reason it
didn't is the people in glass houses
problem and the the further reason
though and this is what drove me so
crazy as a Democrat sitting in Speaker
Wright's office is if you go back in
time this is when we meet with him it's
February 10th 1987 there had been a
series of scandals in the Reagan
administration and there was a major
problem that the Democrats were planning
to use the sleeves factor as it was then
known in the next presidential election
and it's at that juncture that Speaker
right intervenes on behalf of a whole
series of Texas control frauds and then
tries to fire the top regulator the most
prestigious regulator in America at the
behest of the frauds and then went on
from there
it was an amazing thing and he just
handed away the issue and so in the next
race the Democratic candidate mentioned
the savings loan crisis one night the
Republicans shot back with speaker right
within hours and that was never heard
from again because of course right
didn't want that issue raised because he
was now in ethics trouble and it was
eventually cost him his job along with
some you know some other things as well
yes
to most economists but certainly there
are non mainstream non neoclassical
economists who would share your views so
we could turn the question around and
ask why do they get attention in the
media why don't they get government
leaders here that's one question but I
had another one haven't we set up and
weren't you implying that we've set up
an incentive school and binding fraud by
setting up governance structures where
the executives in the corporation get
lots of money when the stock yes ok so
two questions or one's a statement /
question that there are many economists
who are non-mainstream who might well be
supportive of the positions I've been
saying today and there are is quite
correct and why don't they get heard as
much they don't get heard as much for
the usual reasons the folks who control
the journals will not approve articles
under peer-review that say things like
this is a part of the answer but other
people won't fund them as well and most
research is driven by funding so that's
part of it but more often it simply
you're taught as a young economist a
certain thing and that you know you you
believe those things that it shapes your
worldview the second question was am I
suggesting that we've set up in the
governance structure of corporations an
incentive system which is economic
thought is how we approach these topics
that encourages control fraud yes
absolutely and and by the way there are
economic studies showing just this that
fraud is more common when you have
larger stock options and so and this is
critical because these stock options
were sold on the basis that they would
perfectly align the interests of
shareholders and the CEO and so the CEO
would be a faithful agent on behalf of
the shareholders which is great but it's
the old economics joke about assuming
the can opener
because the CEO decides how the stock
options will be structured and we know
empirically how they structure them they
structure them short-term which is the
easiest to manipulate as opposed to
long-term and when the options go what's
called out of the money they restructure
the option so that comes back in the
money so options are supposed to be if
you do very well for the corporation you
too will gain and if you do poorly for
the corporation you will lose and of
course they've changed it to whether or
not the corporation does well you the
CEO will do very well and that creates
incentive structures to mismanage and
even loot the corporation and that's
what control fraud is about yes I argue
explicitly that instead of being a
protection it's one of the more
dangerous things that we've done so Coe
will co-author the next one questions
you ever see the profession
having some finding yes the question is
Alan Greenspan and George Benson were
very active on behalf of Lincoln Savings
in arguing against tree regulation and
have they ever done anything saying
mayor Copa in essence not only have they
never done anything like Mia culpa there
were they paid no price at all for being
as wrong as you possibly could so Alan
Greenspan wrote a letter saying that
Lincoln Savings Pose quote no
foreseeable risk unquote to the Federal
Savings Loan Insurance Corporation and
he did this and supposedly in the basis
of their financial statements well I did
a contemporaneous memorandum I was a kid
right presumptively his financial
analytical abilities are a little beyond
mine mine said the opposite on the basis
of the available information
Greenspan was also used people don't
know this to recruit the Keating five
all right he came in person to recruit
the Keating five and that's I think I'm
the first person to point that out
George Benson did the actual substantive
work because you know Greenspan is a big
man so Ben Stein did a study I mentioned
direct investments earlier and he
praised thirty-four institutions that
had done a number of direct investments
flash-forward two and a half years every
single one of them failed and what is
George Benson right to this day there
was no basis for restricting direct
investments they were wonderful
investments well you know there's no
consequence he got and you know what
happened Alan Greenspan after what he
wrote George Benson got an endowed chair
at Emory and DF ashell who was a
professor who wrote that Lincoln savings
posed no risk to the Federal Savings
Loan Insurance Corporation he became
Dean of the University of Chicago Law
School I mean
I didn't screw up enough you know I've
managed to get it all wrong my career
path would have been so much better it's
hard to believe I'm sure I'll screw up
in the future and perhaps good things
are in time one more so it's an
important one it's the last we're
leaving on that note
temptations to
so the question is are should we be
considering what if anything the
mainstream economists who present these
views and reward people who get things
wrong are serving you know what is their
function why do they can in economic
theory people only get returns if
they're providing value and such a what
value are they providing and that is you
know and the thrust of your question I
fear is correct they they pose value for
the policies that the political folks
believe in so there was a really
striking one in 1983 there was something
called the agenda for reform in which
the bank board brought together a whole
series of condiments including Nobel
Prize winner Fischer black and such and
it was all done by economists the
supervisors the poor pitiful supervisors
were listed underneath the secretaries
and this was not in alphabetical order
right and they write an extraordinary
thing which they didn't tell the public
much they said deregulation in these
circumstances is desperately dangerous
it may cause very large losses but
that's not the danger they were worried
about the danger they was worried about
is those very light at large losses
might lead to re-regulate and that was
the danger that needed to be stopped and
they are explicit about it indeed they
put that quotation on the cover of the
volume to emphasize that was the real
danger
not that we would have losses but that
we would learn from the losses and
engage in reregulate so thank you again
worse thank you
William blackheads the University of
Texas at Austin anti-fraud Institute the
best way to rob a bank is to own one is
published by University of Texas press
more information at you Texas press com